-Welcome back, everybody.
We're joined right now by one
of the most renowned chefs
in the world.
[ Drumroll ]
He's an Emmy
and James Beard Award winner.
His latest book,
"Art of the Chicken,"
will be released
later this fall.
Everyone, please welcome
Chef Jacques Pépin!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Oh, stop.
I'm so excited.
We're so honored and happy
that you're here.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show
and I'm here with Questlove
right here
and I want to ask you
a thousand questions.
I mean, you've cooked
for world leaders,
everything, restaurants.
Julia Child said you're
the greatest chef in America.
-That's a lot.
-Now, what is this experience?
Exactly. Where does
"The Tonight Show" sit with you?
[ Laughter ]
-This is actually not
a cookbook.
It's a book of drawing.
I have 130 drawing of chicken
and story about chicken and egg.
-You did this right here?
You drew this?
-Oh, yeah.
I do a lot of drawing.
Planning and so forth.
-God, that's beautiful.
-Thank you.
-You've been teaching people
for years
all sorts of how to cook
and everything.
And then, can you tell us
what the Pépin Foundation does?
The Jacques Pépin Foundation.
-Oh.
We try to work with coming
into the kitchen
with people who have been
kind of
disenfranchised by life.
People coming out of jail,
former drug addicts,
homeless people,
even veterans, and so forth.
So it's not young people --
30, 40, 50 years old.
My son-in-law and my daughter
are doing it.
They are the greatest.
I would never have done it
without them.
-Wow!
It's amazing what you do
just go give back.
-Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Now, right now,
I was just happy
that you're here.
I was actually just even going
to sit and interview you
and I said, I said,
"Well, let's cook something."
Can you teach us?
What are you going to teach us
how to do,
or or show us how to do?
-I think an omelet.
I'm going to show you how
to make
a classic French omelet.
-Classic French omelet.
-Yes, it's a bit different.
The first thing we do,
we put that on.
So you you just break it down
and its on.
And put a piece of butter
in there.
-Oh, you know what?
-We get the color of those eggs.
-You showed me how to crack
an egg, by the way,
the right way.
-Oh.
You said don't break it
on the edge.
Don't crack it
on the edge of a bowl.
-Exactly.
-Crack it on the flat
because less shell?
-Yeah, because you put
the shell inside,
you introduce bacteria very
often, or you break the yolk.
-Yes, you put three in there.
Check this out right here.
Look at this.
Watch, watch, ready?
Watch this.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
-Wow! He does it with one hand.
-Okay.
-So we want to beat it
and you want to beat it enough
so you don't have long string
of egg whites, you know?
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-Beat it so you don't have
long strings of egg whites.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, so, now,
my butter is melted.
-Oh, I didn't even
put butter in there.
We were supposed to put butter
in there, of course.
-I got you.
-You put butter in there?
-I put butter in it.
-And then, you move
with both hands.
-What in the world?
-Whoa, slow down, slow down!
[ Laughter ]
-What's going on?
Alright. Hold on.
-Okay.
-Butter's in there.
Alright, so --
You're getting some volume!
Getting some volume in yours!
What the heck is going on?!
Hold on, butter out.
-At the end now.
-Wait, I'm putting egg in.
What did you just mix that with?
-Some spinach inside.
[ Laughter ]
What were making
that noise with?
-I fold the lip.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes!
Quest, is yours looking
like this?
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you fold one lip
on the other lip.
You bang it this way.
That bring it on.
-Wait, are you playing drums
right now?
[ Laughter ]
-That's how you make an omelet!
Have you ever been to France,
Quest?!
[ Laughter ]
-That's it, that's it.
Then you fold it.
Now, you fold it.
Oh, ow, ay, ay, ay, ay.
-Alright.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
Right, we have more butter
on that one.
Oh.
-Ope.
Look at this.
And then
cheese.
-Oh, I'm supposed to
-Wow!
-not eat the shells, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. And there you go.
A little cheese on top.
-Sorry about that.
-Or in the middle.
Look at this.
It kind of looks similar.
Ran out of forks.
-You call that an omelet?
[ Laughter ]
-Which one is by the chef
and which one was done by me?
I mean --
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
-We made scrambled eggs.
-He chose mine, though!
-[ Laughs ]
-I love scrambled eggs this way.
[ Rimshot ]
They're even better this way.
-He loves scrambled eggs
that way.
-That's right!
-The one and only Chef --
You want to try mine?
-Yeah.
-I have to try yours.
-Oh.
-Don't answer.
You didn't say anything.
Let me try yours.
[ Laughter ]
-I think yours tastes
better than mine.
-Nuh-unh.
That's the most delicious thing
[ Cheering and applause ]
I've ever had in my life.
-Thank you.
-Jacques Pépin!
Ooh!
-Shall we have some wine?
-Oh, now you can come back
whenever you like.
I love you.
Jacques Pépin.
His book "Art of the Chicken"
will be available
September 13th.
To learn more about the
Jacques Pépin Foundation,
go to jp.foundation.